okay
i'm ready whenever you're ready okay
all right well dressed as a perfect man
of fashion
amanda fashion that's it all right louis
louis uh where'd you grow up where are
you from i'm from meridian mississippi
and uh tell me about your uh your
childhood you had both your parents
both parents and they was together about
57 years
i just recently lost my mother and
father i'm sorry i said
you good childhood yes we stayed in
school
i grew up in mississippi but i grew up
like
in poverty you know yeah mississippi is
one of the poorest yes i guess it was
so we would have to chase the excuse me
for sanders the white man cows
have stayed out of school to chase his
cows in
say it again white man cows will get out
and we would have to chase them back in
stay out of school
and chase them back in your job was to
keep the cops from getting away yes
you would tell us stay out of school
don't go to school today my cows are out
so we'll put them back in and if the
cows were behaving you guys went to
school
yes i understand if they're all up we go
to school
he would come and ask my mother to keep
us out of school
so i grew up doing that what was it like
i had a rough life so you were born what
year 1963
63. so what was it like being a black
man in mississippi back in the early 60s
mid 60s wow it was hard it was hard
because uh
they were in that segregate segregation
stuff you know what i mean
so uh we had to pretty much watch our
step and
watch who we talked to we couldn't talk
to white people you know
it was just rough it was just wrong yeah
yeah the racism
but i don't have that in me it was was
strong down in the city yes
yes it is still still is yeah is today
so uh at some point you got introduced
to
being a pimp yes how did that happen
well i
met this young lady she was 45 and i was
only 17.
i kind of fell in love with her but she
i literally i know she was a prostitute
so she brought me into the game and kind
of schooled me and grew me
and uh the rest i kind of pretty much
learned
from other pimps talking to them going
out to dinner and
this and that did you have any pips in
the family yes my uncle your uncle
yes he's a well-dressed man as well
yeah and he lived in cleveland ohio yeah
ohio is big on february yes
it was yeah what uh what kind of stuff
did he teach you as a young man
he taught me to groom your woman
let her know what you want what you want
him to do
and put him in your class name that
class
pimping 101.
so in that class we i would tell them
what i expected them
let them know that i was going to handle
all the money i'll buy all their clothes
i'll feed them and i would do everything
i would house them
so that's that's what that class was all
about what was the arrangement
financially how much of the money
did you keep i kept all of it all of it
anything they needed i bought that's the
typical answer yeah
they may come to me for this and that
and the other but i always break them
off
a lot of i think people that aren't
familiar with
the world of pimps and prostitutes are
mystified if
yes they explain how a female
comes to you and wants you to be her
pimp and wants to give you 100 of her
money
typical example i had one to come up and
she said
i like your style i would like to be one
of your
girls i said you want me to pimp you
she was like yes so that was my second
one
you know uh so we
eventually pulled three more ins so i
had five all together
you had five girls yes and this was in
the 70s
this is in the 70s yes
have you ever been arrested for this yes
once
but the laws have changed directly yes
they have yes yeah
are you still active today uh yeah
but uh it's under different
circumstances no it's not like the old
days when you were
right exactly i was into money
houses and cars but now
you know stuck on them little drugs
things happen
you know what i mean yeah eventually i'm
going to get off that but i still dress
i
i i you know my pride and my dignity
just won't let me so drugs kind of get
got the best of you
yes recently wait what what drug is that
is that uh
that's uh cocaine correct cocaine yeah
so back back to the what you were doing
in the 70s uh
how much was like robbing john's
part of the part of the game robin john
i mean like it wasn't pure was it purely
just sex for money or was it sometimes
sex and then tricking guys out of their
money and right
i would tell them to pretty much
evaluate the guys they date because
you never know who you might meet in
that class i taught them how to evaluate
a guy
but for the most part you make good
money
i would set a price and they would go go
with the price that i said
but for instance if i tell them 200
nothing no less than that but if a guy
if it's clear a guy might have money
right then
other games are played and you try to
get them out absolutely i will tell them
kind of evaluate how much money they
spend how much they talk about their
money
what they have and kind of peep game
and shoot for example i had one to make
two thousand dollars
of one guy because she evaluated him and
what happened he had a lot of money he
had a lot of homes and
and i told him i told her to go for the
gusto so she did that
were you married when you were doing
this i was married
once but it was later on you know
i married a 45 year old oh you married
her yes
so she was quite a bit older than you
yes she was and she wanted me to get out
of the game but i just couldn't because
it was too much money too much good
money
i explained to her yeah you know so so
you were still
working as a pimp and she was out of the
out of the game
no she wanted to get out i wouldn't let
him because she was my
height of life you know she was pretty
much in charge you know
every night and then she'd go out and
make a little money for the most part i
didn't want to out there
making a whole lot of money nine things
had gotten kind of dangerous so
you know it's it's kind of rough now
yeah the laws are much stricter right
yes it is
the penalties instead of being six
months or a year are now yes they'll try
to
you know strike you out if you're too
striking yeah even though you'll be
going to court
fighting the case you know so what would
when one of your girls
would get headstrong and get a little
bit out of line
what would you do about it well i would
[Music]
put hands on it and it's sad to say but
at that time you had to keep them in
line because
not they would take control you know
what i mean so i wouldn't i wasn't gonna
have that
and these are black women white women
well i have
one let's see three blacks
one was asian and black and i had one
white
and and these girls would stick around
for how long they
they stayed around for 20 years 20 years
so you you're doing something right yeah
that was good i loved it i loved it
but what are the qualities you think
pimp needs to to do this to be
successful
well you got to have street street
knowledge
for sure because you got to know what
zone to go in what zone not to go in
you got to be able to um
stand your ground in other words because
if not you have something out there to
just take control
we want you on the street and they'll
let you down
so you have to pretty much you know
stand your ground
and what qualities do you look for in a
woman
sexy nice body you know smell good
by the way i was buying all that
name brand could uh perfume uh name
brand clothing
take a shower three times a day you know
my growth was just
well grown so so you your job as a pimp
is to dress them
yes give them a life that makes it
pretty much guide them you know what i'm
saying
i would lead them through everything
okay it's time for you to take a shower
it's almost like you're a boyfriend
husband whatever yes
exactly do you think there's some bit of
uh
them looking for a you to replace the
father figure they
may have never had or for the most part
yes for that relationship
for the most part yes but i also was
having sex with all of them so you know
it was my own there's my [ __ ] you
know i'm sorry to say but
that's what they were but i would also
you know get my issue so drugs have
kind of taken hold of your uh your life
a bit now yes
uh now i i don't do it every day
but um i do it every night i did i
basically started doing it on the
weekends
and that weekend uh caught me up down
here and i've been here ever since
yeah you told me yeah drugs are your
pimp
they have my pimp yeah my pimp they're
your pimp yeah yeah so they
they they force you to work yes yeah but
i got
a few girls i put out there you know and
i don't go hard in the paint like i used
to you know
but uh i would tell want to go out there
and get it they'll go get it
and what what kind of uh lifestyle would
you lead when you were at your
at your peak i mean you had houses and
cars and stuff like that yes in the
beginning i had i had five hundred
thousand dollars at one time because i
was pimping real hard in mississippi
because i had
you know a lot of girls that would come
and bring me money just because i was a
good looking man dressing nice you know
what i'm saying i used to wear the
nicest suits nice gator shoes
and i was just smelling good they would
just bring me money
and i also was a dancer i would dance
for the fat girls
you know uh that brought a lot of money
extra five six hundred
the fat girls would pay you to dance yes
yes
interesting but i'll give about 500 a
night to do that so
you know you're just making money making
money everywhere yeah i was able to buy
me a
two-story house which i lost all that
i had about five or six cars i'm saying
i would buy those expensive cars like
bmw mercedes
you know jaguar stuff like that and i
had a brand new truck
i had a little low rider truck it was a
67
uh i had a 67 chevy truck
i bought it out i did that myself and uh
it was just life is just good i would do
body work on it myself and all that
yeah your kids yes and you raised them
yes all together i have about 12 kids
but uh i was with four of them all my
life you know what i'm saying
i was going around making babies no how
many different women
uh
[Music]
and your kids knew you were doing this
no i never brought them into that
lifestyle i would take care of them
but they didn't knew what i was doing
they thought i was working
i would go out every night they thought
i was going to work working as what
uh i told him i worked at budweiser
i had a shirt that i would wear home
every night
have you ever been lucky what's that
have you ever been in love yes
yes uh i love that uh 45 year old she
was
much older than i was but and he took a
took a toll so i just kind of eventually
let the pimpy game go because i would
introduce crack
and uh it kind of tore my mouth out a
little bit
but i've always dressed nice you know
saying kept a car
you know did the girls that worked for
you were they using drugs
yes yes i would buy their drugs
i'll buy their clothing i'll make sure
they take a nice bath
you know a shower three times a day that
was a must
and i would go take them to macy's and
places like that to get them
the expensive perfume jc pennies
but uh i had top of the line girls
they was all nice and fine cocobala's
figure uh they was just beautiful
what's what's the craziest thing you
you've seen in all in your years of
doing this
in mostly mississippi right yes did you
do it in l.a as well
yes i brought it out here to l.a
uh i only did it about two years because
it got too rough up there because i was
on weston
i had uh i had broken down to three
girls
on weston but uh i was getting into it
every
every weekend with someone so i just had
to back out the game before i uh
you know so during your career was the
craziest thing you you recall
the craziest thing was
uh maybe having sex with all five of
them at one time
never do it that would do it that
may strike kind of hard but i did that
you know we would just have you know fun
they loved it you know so i was kind of
crazy and young you know
so and your clientele would be
my clientele mostly white men's a lot of
money
yeah especially when i take him to
hollywood
oh we would clean up that's when i was
making five thousand dollars a night and
you know
but i just love it you know but you have
to be on your dog because people out
there to try to take you out because
they don't want you
making all the money so
i i felt that for a long time you know
pulling guns getting shot at you know
i'm saying
but i hung in there i hung in there a
good
five or six more years and then i said i
got to give it up my kids got to scream
and daddy you're going to get hurt you
know
later on in life they learned that i was
a pimp yeah
so but uh so i just sat him down and
told him what i was doing
they seemed like they were shocked but
they understood my daughter is
she went to cal state dominguez she
graduated uh
she got a degree in political science i
encouraged her to go to grad school
so i paid for all that which was
beautiful
so your kids do well yes yes all of them
all of them they all finished high
school and i made sure i took care of
them
excellent yes all right louis thank you
so much for sharing your story
not a problem really appreciate your
eyes i appreciate you
thank you